SPEAKER: Welcome back
to another episode
of "BigQuery Spotlight."
Today, we're talking about
BigQuery data governance
so that everyone in
your organization
can easily find and
leverage the data they
need to make
effective decisions,
while minimizing overall
risk and ensuring
regulatory compliance.
Let's jump in.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The term data governance is
thrown around quite a bit,
but what does it actually mean?
Data governance
is everything you
do to ensure your data is
secure, private, accurate,
available, and usable
inside of BigQuery.
For us, governance starts
during data onboarding.
Let's say your team has
received a new request.
Someone from your
e-commerce department
wants to add transactions data
into a new BigQuery table.
The first step in
ensuring governance
is understanding the data.
For example, figuring out
where the data is coming from
and what information
it contains.
In this case, the
transactions will
be extracted from a
database, and you already
know the schema.
So let's start by creating
a new blank BigQuery table.
Next, you'll need to make
sure that sensitive data is
protected.
To do so, you'll want to
categorize the information
in your new table.
For example, marking
specific columns
as having personally
identifiable information.
You might remember that
tables can have labels.
While labels are a great
way to easily categorize
BigQuery objects, they
are a bit limited,
and can't be used
for specific columns.
Lucky for us, BigQuery
has deep integrations
with Data Catalog, Google
Cloud's data discovery
and metadata management service.
Data Catalog automatically
tracks technical metadata
for BigQuery assets.
So we can already find
our new BigQuery table,
and see things like column
names, descriptions and when
it was created.
But the really cool
part is that you
can create schematized tags
that act as annotations
to capture metadata.
We've already created
a tag template
that tracks data
governance information, so
now let's fill it in and attach
the tag to the Email column.
Great.
Now we're tracking that this
entity contains customer email
addresses.
But you might also notice
there's a Comments column
that stores freeform
text customers have
added to their order.
There's a chance that
some of these rows
contain more
sensitive information.
This is where DLP comes in.
DLP, or Cloud Data
Loss Prevention,
is Google Cloud's
service designed
to help you discover and protect
your most sensitive data.
With DLP, you can create an
inspection job that scans
comments for email addresses.
DLP can scan data that lives
in Data Store, Google Cloud
Storage, or BigQuery,
and can send you
an email with the scan results,
save the results of that
to a table inside of BigQuery,
or even write the results
directly into Data Catalog.
Many BigQuery users choose
to leverage an orchestration
tool, like Cloud
Composer, to build
data onboarding pipelines.
For example, you might
load your transactions data
in a locked down staging
project inside of BigQuery
and kick off a DLP scan
when new comments are added.
The results will be listed in
the staging table's metadata
inside of Data Catalog.
If the scan shows that any
sensitive information is
included in a comment,
then you can also
kick off a D
identification workflow,
where DLP replaces
PII with something
like an asterisk
or a hash symbol.
Then, the new data is finally
appended to the production
BigQuery table.
Now that you've de-identified
and classified your data,
you're ready to design
access policies.
To understand data
access in BigQuery,
you need to familiarize
yourself with Identity Access
Management, or IAM.
If you haven't already watched
our video on BigQuery IAM,
I recommend pausing
and taking a look.
We've linked it in
the comments below.
Great, so on to data sharing.
When it comes to granting
access to BigQuery data,
many administrators
choose to grant
Google Groups representing your
company's different departments
access to specific data
sets or projects so policies
are simple to manage.
Say you have a project that
stores your organization's
e-commerce data.
You might give the e-commerce
team the BigQuery Data Viewer
role in this project.
Now, if someone on
the e-commerce team
needs data from
a different team,
like the product
development department,
you may be inclined
to just grant them
access to that data set.
Instead, you could use
an authorized view,
or an authorized UDF, so that
your e-commerce analyst can
get limited access
to product data
while still keeping more
manageable team to project
permissions.
So this all sounds great, but
what about those PII columns
that we flagged before
in Data Catalog?
You definitely don't
want the e-com team
to have access to those, unless
they have special clearance
from security.
With BigQuery, you
can control access
to specific columns using
policy tags from Data Catalog.
Here, we've created
a taxonomy, which
classifies the level of
clearance needed to access
different types of data.
Anyone who needs access to
our highly sensitive data
should be added as a
fine-grained reader
to the high resource.
So in our case, we'll just add
the e-com PII clearance group.
Next, we can apply
these as policy tags
to columns in our
BigQuery table,
marking the columns with
PII as highly sensitive.
And to take it one
step further, maybe you
don't want all e-commerce
folks to get access
to the transactions data.
Instead, each
analyst should only
be able to view
transactions for the product
category they work on.
You can control access
to specific rows
in BigQuery using a
row-level access policy,
like the one we're showing here.
Between storing data
in different containers
and leveraging authorized
views, UDFs, policy tags,
and row-level
access policies, you
have a lot of options
for sharing data
in a secure manner.
Check out the documentation
below for some more guidance
on pros and cons
and general best
practices for policy access.
OK, so we've onboarded our
data set and we've shared it.
The last step we'll talk
about is ongoing monitoring,
including ensuring
that data is accurate.
This is where data
quality comes in.
There are lots of
different tools
that allow you to declare
quality validation
tests by writing custom
assertions using SQL.
For example, you may want
to check and make sure
that you don't have
any duplicate entries
in your table.
We've actually created
an open source framework
for data quality
validation that's
included in the comments below.
And keep an eye
out for Data Form,
our tool for developing
SQL pipelines,
which will be open to
new customers soon.
Just like we
mentioned before, you
can use an orchestration
tool like Cloud Composer
to programmatically
run these tests
and alert you if
something seems wrong.
You can also use the Data
Catalog API to make sure
that quality metadata
is added to tags
and is easily discoverable.
Aside from monitoring
quality, you
might also want to monitor
who's accessing the data
and how they're using it.
Well, you're in luck.
In a few weeks, we're diving
into monitoring your BigQuery
deployment, so be
sure to tune in.
And remember, stay curious.
[MUSIC PLAYING]